[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron et volodymeersky ont
embarqué dans l'avion Falcon de la
présidente française ce jeudi matin
depuis l'aéroport de Vélizy-Villacoublay
dans les Yvelines ils sont arrivés à
Bruxelles quelques heures après pour se
rendre au sommet des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement de l'Union européenne le
président ukrainien devrait y demander
un nouveau renforcement de l'aide
militaire à l'Ukraine c'est insolite
plusieurs habitants de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ont reçu plus
d'une dizaine d'amendes de stationnement
chacun en cause un bug informatique de
l'application PayByPhone qui permet de
payer les forfaits post stationnement de
la ville ils se sont accumulés pendant
près d'un an et ont été envoyés
simultanément la semaine dernière la
municipalité assure cependant que les
usagers bénéficient d'un certain délai
pour effectuer leur démarche en ligne ou
envoyer leurs contestation par voie
postale
Île-de-France mobilité annoncé une
campagne de remboursement pour les
détenteurs du Pass Navigo en cause la
dégradation de la qualité des services
des bus et métro entre septembre et
décembre 2022 et les Ret des RER B et D
en 2022 vous pourrez vous faire
rembourser jusqu'à un mois d'abonnement
la plateforme de remboursement ouvrira
le 14 mars prochain le jeune joueur de
rugby 5 continents Enzo Benegal connaît
sa deuxième sélection en équipe de
France U20 l'encadrement tricolore a en
effet dévoilé l'équipe qui sera alignée
face à l'Irlande pour la deuxième
journée du Tournoi des 6 nations de
moins de 20 ans Enzo benmegal fait
partie des 15 joueurs qui disputeront le
match ce sera demain soir à 21h enfin si
vous êtes étudiant et que vous
recherchez un emploi sachez que les
services de l'État souhaite former et
recruter 3000 étudiants et jeunes pour
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 les postes concernent les métiers
de la sécurité privée pour la
surveillance des abords des
manifestations ou encore le contrôle de
sécurité à l'entrée des stades la
formation de 106 heures est gratuite et
rémunérée pour en bénéficier vous devez
vous inscrire comme demandeur d'emploi
sur une plateforme dédiée de Pôle emploi
et remplir le questionnaire sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]